and you can't have a birthday without  puppies  yep  and backstage are some furry friends who  are actually up for adoption  that's right where are kyla tucker and  lindsay poochow oh hi ladies come on up  you know i was just thinking i heard  that maybe just maybe you guys are open  to possible adoption oh yeah most  definitely um move here from kankakee  illinois so it'd be nice to start you  know family and get a little guy or girl  um and are you possibly open to adoption  yeah we're looking to get a dog as soon  as we can so okay well  so let me  this is  this is um beezus  yup and this is ramona  and  you know  you guys you just go ahead backstage and  see if you bond and you know we'll check  in with you no pressure  thank you so much for coming you guys  thank you thank you  [Music]  [Music]  you